يقول المدعون الأوكرانيون إن هذه هي
اللحظة
التي ارتكب فيها
الجنود الروس جريمة حرب لا يمكن إنكارها.
تبين أن هدفهم هو اثنين من
المدنيين الأوكرانيين المطمئنين وغير المسلحين الذين أطلقوا النار عليهم في الخلف ، وقد
أبلغنا أولاً في هذا الجزء من
الفيديو في أنه قد يُظهر صاحب العمل
يموت حيث يسقط والحارس على
قيد الحياة في البداية ولكنه ينزف حتى
الموت بعد إعادته إلى  كوخ حارسه كان
كلا الرجلين قد قضيا الدقائق القليلة الماضية
يتحدثان بهدوء مع الجنود الروس
الذين بدا أنهم سمحوا لهم بالرحيل ،
لكننا نرى الآن اثنين من الجنود
يعودون ويطلقون النار عليهم.
ثم أرادت أن يعرف العالم
اسم والدها وما فعله الروس
به جوليا هل شاهدت الفيديو
لا يمكنني مشاهدته  الآن
سأحفظها على السحابة وأتركها
لأحفادي وأولادي
يجب أن يعرفوا عن هذه الجريمة وأن يتذكروا دائمًا من
هم جيراننا والآن
يقول مكتب المدعي العام في
bucha بمساعدة قصة CNN أنه قد
حدد أخيرًا أحد جلاديه
أبلغ اسم المشتبه به نيكولاي سيرجيفيتش
سوكوفوكوف أوكرانيا روسيا أن
التحقيق السابق للمحاكمة قد
ركز على سوخوفاكوف باعتباره مرتكب جريمة
القتل بدم بارد في
حين أن المدعين لن يكشفوا
بالضبط عن كيفية التعرف على هذا
الجندي بالذات
رأينا جزءًا واحدًا من العملية
يتم استخدامها من قبل المسؤولين الأوكرانيين
لتقنية التعرف على الوجه ، إنها سريعة حقًا ، حيث
تحصل وزارة التحول الرقمي على صورة وتحمّلها في البرنامج
الذي أنشأته وتنظف وسائل التواصل الاجتماعي التي
تبحث عن مباراة
بمجرد أن يكون لديهم مباراة لجندي
حيا أو ميتًا يحاولون تأكيد ذلك.  مع
الأصدقاء والعائلة على مواقع التواصل الاجتماعي للجندي ،
تعرفنا على حوالي 300 ج  كما
يقول إن
التعرف على المشتبه به الأخير
بارتكاب جرائم حرب
استغرق شهورًا في الإعداد ، لكنه على الأقل خطوة واحدة نحو تحقيق العدالة بالنسبة للعائلات التي سلبت شيئًا منها ، فلا يمكنهم أبدًا استعادة حياة شخص أحبوه سارة سيدنر سي إن إن  نيويورك